nada más repite siempre aquí se te nota
en la cara tienes un niño amado y feliz
casi en la misma cantidad de veces que
me repite afeites ese bigote demarrar lo
que le sale
dos cosas
pero antes de detener el pozo del 1 hubo
un momento en el que realmente él no era
feliz
durante los tres primeros años en el
bachillerato sufrir el matón
en 66 séptima la me estaba realmente
porque lo que quieras además de mi valor
[Música]
todo hasta mis 13 años o como a mí me
gusta llamarlos la cruel e ingrata
llegada de la pubertad
y no sólo llegó con cambios hormonales
el pelo en lugares donde no sabía que
podía haber pelo sino que me enfrento
cara a cara a uno de los males más
heridos es que existen
la crisis adolescente
mientras pasaba todos estos cambios esta
metamorfosis y una parte importante en
mi papá no grabando no me se murió
simplemente le salió una excelente
oportunidad de trabajo en méxico que lo
ayudará a cumplir sus metas
profesionales
yo deseo apoyarlo porque hashtag es
mejor llamar por el mundo pero que yo
quisiera verlos felices realizado no
significaba que no me doliera su partida
esta decisión trae muchos cambios
inesperados comienzo a vivir más tiempo
con mi mamá que tiene que manejar entre
trabajar y estar conmigo para cubrir los
gastos que aunque papá nos ayudaba no
tenía cuando vivía con él
como les conté está experimentando las
iniciales del p
dudas sobre mi lugar en el mundo dudas
sobre mis ideales el cuerpo me comenzó a
crecer de una manera que yo me entendía
primero un brazo luego otro cel y sancho
la cabeza se le volvió a acomodar yo era
un muñeco en las habilidades especiales
el bolis de comida a ser más fuerte
porque me canso de fingir que me
gustaban los que a un niño le debía
gustar
fútbol- objetivizar a las mujeres hablar
de por lo cosas que al parecer define a
mi masculinidad y si no me gustaban
eliminaban el hecho de que yo fuera
hombre
tratar de buscar ayuda y refugio en un
adulto con una profesora
que me dice mi amor es tu culpa si
quieres ser aceptado tienes que cambiar
una frase que obviamente nos ayudó me
sentí mejor contario
no quería apoyar mis papás porque sentí
que en ese momento tenían mucho con que
cargar y yo debía apoyar los entonces
ahorrarles un problema
había desaparecido toda la base de
personas que me pueden apoyar o
simplemente yo no la quería ver
en este momento
es cuando la oscuridad toca mi puerta
me dice
hola estoy aquí y yo le digo / está en
su casa
llegó en forma de texto o como es
conocido coloquialmente pasar el pac
una forma en la que yo creí que si
aceptaba mi físico
yo me aprobaría
pero seis meses en los que al principio
pensé que ha encontrado mi lugar pero en
los que al final sólo logré perder mi
alma y mi gozo
no recuerdo nada de esos momentos y se
hizo controlar super bien yo creo que de
lo traumático que fue lo que sé es por
lo que me cuentan las personas alrededor
de mí y yo parece un top comida por
inercia estudiaba por inercia inclusive
me reía por inercia
en ese momento
pasa pasa y una noche se acaba todo
vino más escucha una voz que le dice
revisa el celular de juan esteban
cuando entra pero cuesta contar tus
bloqueados pero no se entiende su
búsqueda sigue sigue
descubriendo todo lo que yo había hecho
volviéndose loca por no saber qué hacer
llamó mi papá ya lloran durante cuatro
horas
y se pone inaugural
a la siguiente mañana me manda al
colegio y cuando llego me dice juan en
que te metiste
yo cambié mi postura corporal de una
manera sorprendente estaba encorvado
todo el tiempo me empecé en mi mente era
quitarme la maleta llena de rocas que
representaban todo lo caminaría
siguiendo con las investigaciones
acudimos a la policía una entidad que la
verdad nos apoyó mucho y que no sólo nos
brindó soluciones sino que nos hizo
comprender los riesgos a los que yo me
enfrente
de los contactos uno era un secuestrador
y violador de menores otro eran
traficados de órganos y otro era una red
de prostitución infantil
obviamente todos es cuidados bajo
perfiles perfiles falsos
entender a los 13 años los riesgos de
exponer tu intimidad es algo que yo no
le deseo a nadie porque es tocar un
abismo y no tener la más remota idea de
cómo salir pero
había dañado mi corazón
y no sabía cómo curarlo
así que adicional a la ayuda de mis
papás
y una buena amiga psicóloga que encontré
con el tiempo
comienza un viaje personal
iglesias libros de autoayuda páginas de
internet psicólogos algo que me hiciera
entender por qué hice lo que hice y cómo
podía volver a darme a mí mismo
comienza por abraham maslow el primero
actual en definir el auto estilo que
dice que es la necesidad de respetarse a
uno mismo
algo del principio en este sentido pero
mientras más lo contestaba con mi
realidad era como decir no pega porque
yo no necesitaba el otro respeto ni lo
necesita en ese momento ni le considera
una vamos a un abismo para crearlo de la
nada
así que decidió descartar esta idea y
todas las que se encontraban en libros
de tres por diez mil
y pasó a la psicóloga del colegio
otra profesional algo confundida que me
dice que el amor propio es verte el
lindo en el espejo una idea que me
aterraba mucho porque yo ya me sentía
bien con mi físico pero había algo en mi
estómago que me decía que yo no estaba
cuando puntillo era
mi mano de la búsqueda y lanza al cerro
la autoestima
y en ese momento la condenada se aparece
la dignidad de uno puede ser agredida
vandalizada y cruelmente escarnecida
pero no puede arrebatar se a menos que
una estrella
aparece esta frase de michael fox quien
hace call de algún pensamiento
rotundamente entender que no era lo que
decía más yo lo necesitaba el auto
respeto yo me lo merecía
porque no hay nadie más digna de mi amor
que yo
en este momento se le materia
la práctica llegó cuando conocí a mi
primer y mejor amigo
ya seis años de amistad que me enseñó
qué
el autoestima lo iba a conseguir en el
momento que yo dejara la imagen falsa
que el mundo quería ver de mí
y me enamorara y descubriera que él
realmente yo era
entiendo todo esto veo que mi hipótesis
si era cierta y hago cambios radicales
en libia el cambio de colegio le damos
lugar con personas increíblemente
maravillosas diferentes a mí en
muchísimos aspectos pero que estamos de
acuerdo en una cosa
queríamos encontrar un lugar en el mundo
donde pudiéramos ser buenos seres
humanos siendo auténticos
eso no significa que no me tropiezo
a veces la embargo y feo porque a mí
obviamente no tengo la cura de los males
emocionales
pero tengo claro que si me caigo hay
gente que va a estar ahí para mí que no
va a levantar y que me va a sostener
en estos momentos
en cuanto usted se pregunta esto hay que
decirlo
porque me voy triste
muy bonita lo que yo viví de pronto hay
cosas peores sí lo sé pero lo importante
es usted que puede sacar de esto
cuando conté por primera vez la historia
una mira
me dijo muchas de las crisis que los
adolescentes van ligadas a la dignidad
porque la primera historia que oigo así
de pronto si supiéramos esto no
cometeríamos tantas adolescent hadas o
peleadas como ya le llaman
así que digo lo que yo viví sirva para
algo yo me salvé por algo así que tengo
que resignificar lo que yo viví
y investigar pero esta vez me encuentro
con cosas no tan chévere
en el 2017 en colombia 1550 niños
adolescentes y jóvenes entre los 10 y 19
años fueron atendidos por anorexia
nueve mil ochocientos fueron atendidos
pero trastornos de ansiedad no
especificada
y 22.000 fueron atendidos por depresión
pero la cifra más macabra con la que me
encontré es que en el 2018 4444 mil
cuatrocientos veinte jóvenes entre los
10 34 años se suicidaron en nuestro país
esto no me sorprende la tierra pero no
me sorprende porque como sociedad somos
culpables de esto a los jóvenes nos
enseñan que tenemos que seguir el status
quo la falsa belleza externa lo que
dicen las redes sociales que antes de
seguir lo que dice el corazón y la
cabeza para ser felices tenemos que
pasar por encima de los demás
porque yo soy feliz cuando logré lo que
quería pero soy mucho más feliz cuando
veo que el otro no pudo
a todos nos han pisoteado el amor propio
así como también en los pisos de aves de
los demás
este es el momento de cambiar la
conciencia de unidad de hablar de
respeto de cohesión social de
construcción de hacernos cargo nosotros
lo que hacemos en redes sociales en
nuestras publicaciones sino hacer de
nuestro poder y fuerza una herramienta
que transforme que integre que inspiren
que construyan y que trascienda porque
la historia es una de muchas una de
muchas posiblemente más valiosas pero la
suma de muchas historias como los
pudieron ver y lo van a ver son las que
nos van a enseñar que merecemos un lugar
increíble en este mundo y que hacernos
daño a nosotros o hacerle daño a alguien
más no debería ser nunca una opción
tenemos que reflexionar sobre nuestro
deber como ciudadanos de los estándares
inalcanzables que ponemos si a los
jóvenes se nos pidiera ser feliz con lo
que soñamos con metas propias con
ideales no sólo académicos sino también
colaborativos constructivos
tendremos una sociedad con seres humanos
fuertes
que nunca pero nunca van a negociar su
dignidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]